today we're going to compare firebase to
AWS amplify both of which are platforms
that make it easy for app developers to
manage and scale their cloud
infrastructure in this video we'll build
a mini JavaScript app on both platforms
so we can compare feature parity the
developer experience and pricing show
time you're new here like and subscribe
and check out the full write-up on fire
ship IO now for full disclosure I am a
huge fan of firebase and have been using
it for many years while AWS amplify was
only released in 2018 the first major
difference to point out is that amplify
will run on Amazon's cloud
infrastructure while firebase will run
on Google's so there will be some degree
of vendor lock-in there but that's just
the trade-off you make if you want to
dramatically simplify it back-end you're
mine now you belong to me you're not
gonna have your mommies around behind
you anymore why pillow douches let's
start by looking at some of the core
features offered by both platforms and I
should point out that this isn't a one
is better than the other type of
comparison it's more about using the
right tool for the job and the first
thing you'll need to know is whether or
not your friend and framework is
supported you'll find official support
for iOS Android and the web and with
amplify you'll also find official
support for react native as well as
react web angular and view at the time
of this video it does not support water
or bundling with roll-up but there are
open issues for those so they may be
supported in the future with firebase
you do have official support for flutter
and angular and view both have official
libraries under their mano repose for
firebase and there are some really good
community maintained projects for react
and react native now let's take a look
at the core features of these platforms
starting with the things that they share
in common they both provide user
authentication analytics a way to manage
real time data push notifications file
storage service functions and web
hosting well look at all these one by
one throughout the video but what does
amplifi offer that firebase does not
come with me if you want to live one of
the first things I noticed was the
ability to set up dedicated environments
for development and production you can
do this in firebase as well by just
setting up multiple projects but it's a
little more streamlined here and another
thing that's more streamlined is setting
up your continuous deployment amplifi
takes a very similar approach to natla
fie where you connect to your hosting
account to a github repo then when you
commit your code it just automatically
deploys that code to the hosting account
now in all fairness you can do this with
google cloud build and firebase as well
there's just a few more configuration
steps to get it set up another unique
feature of amplifi is its integration
with graph queue
which we'll look at closely in a few
minutes and the last thing I'll point
out is its integration with Sumerian
which might be useful if you're building
an Augmented or virtual reality app so
that's pretty cool but what does
firebase have that amplify does not the
first and most interesting thing is a
dedicated database and we'll compare
that in detail to amplifies graph QL
setup and another feature in firebase
that I find to be very powerful is
callable functions these are service
functions that you can call with the
auth context from your front-end so you
can easily tell on your back-end code if
a user is logged in or not and that's a
lot easier than setting up an API
gateway or just writing the backend
authorization logic from scratch in
firebase you also have a few tools for
quality control things like crashlytics
performance and test lab and then you
have quite a few more features that are
built on top of your analytics things
like predictions and remote config to
name a few and you also have ml kit
which makes it really easy to implement
machine learning features both in the
cloud and on device now let's go ahead
and switch gears to pricing if you've
ever shopped on amazon.com you'll know
that they push prices to the absolute
bottom that's just built into Amazon's
DNA and culture and we can see that with
AWS pricing going back 10 years in the
past
we'll find a price of 15 cents per
gigabyte in an s3 storage bucket and if
we fast forward to the present day it's
only 2.3 cents per gigabyte that's a
price reduction of 85 percent over the
course of 10 years
but it's a little more complex than that
both platforms have extremely generous
pricing models and they both start out
on a free tier so you don't really pay
for anything until you have a decent
number of active users and what you'll
find on most services is that EWS is
just slightly cheaper than GCP for
example a gigabyte of storage is 2.3
cents on AWS and 2.6 on firebase but
firebase has a couple of services that
are always free such as user
authentication and push notifications on
AWS you pay about half a penny for each
monthly active user be on fifty thousand
monthly active users but the most
interesting pricing comes into play when
we start talking about databases and
real time listeners to that data with
firestore you're billed for your reads
and writes to the database and all the
real-time syncing just happens
automatically so you don't really have
to worry much about that as far as
pricing is concerned on AWS you have a
service called app sync which will
connect automatically to a DynamoDB
instance and with app sync you pay $4
per 1 million query or write operations
but with firestore that would only be 60
cents if they're read operations or $1
80 if they were write operations in
addition with app sync you might have
additional costs associated with the
actual back-end database itself and they
also calculate billing in chunks of five
kilobytes so if you have a document
that's a hundred kilobytes that would
equal 50 document read units it is hard
to compare these things side-by-side but
this appears to be an area where
firestore would be significantly less
expensive as an app scales up and last
thing I'll mention on pricing is that
AWS does have a solid edge when it comes
to service costing 20 cents per million
function invocations versus 40 cents on
firebase now pricing is an important
thing to consider but the whole reason
you would use a framework like amplifier
firebase in the first place is to
increase the speed and flexibility of
development so what I've done here is
built a little to-do app that has user
authentication and a real time to-do
list it's built with spelt three and
will just use it to compare the
developer experience between both
platforms we'll go ahead and start with
amplify so at this point you need to
have an AWS developer account and also
the amplify CLI installed on your system
from there we'll run amplify an int
which will set up a project in our
working directory it'll ask us a series
of basic questions and it also gives us
the option to set up amplify with a
popular JavaScript framework but we'll
just go ahead and select none for
vanilla Jas that'll take a minute to
complete and then when
it's done it will create this amplified
directory in the root of the project and
that just contains a reference to all
the AWS resources that we're using in
this project now we can connect
authentication to this app by running
amplify add-on that'll give us a few
different options here but we'll go with
the most simple use case of just email
password authentication and once we
selected those options we can go ahead
and run amplify push this will take all
the resources that we have staged
locally for AWS and then actually
allocate them in the cloud in this case
user authentication is handled by an AWS
service called Cognito if we go to the
AWS console you'll see a user pool based
on the app that you just created and
inside of here you'll find all kinds of
different configuration options and this
is an area where AWS has a big advantage
over firebase in terms of flexibility
and customization it allows you to do
things like multi factor auth by sending
a text message or email to the user with
a special code that they need to verify
and you can also set up custom
attributes on the user authentication
record and you also have additional
triggers that you can use for serverless
code in firebase you can only trigger
when a user is created or deleted but
with Cognito you have additional places
that you can hook in serverless code now
if we switch over to the firebase
dashboard you'll find that things are a
lot more simplified things are generally
faster and easier to set up but they are
less flexible by comparison for example
if we wanted to set up password list
authentication we can just do that by
clicking a button
whereas on AWS we can do that as well
but we'd have to set up several lambda
functions to make it happen now once we
have the initial configuration done the
code for both platforms looks very
similar on my AWS amplifi branch I had
to switch over to web pack and spelt
because apparently it doesn't work with
roll-up currently and just a quick side
note here both amplify and firebase will
add quite a bit of JavaScript to your
final bundle size for firebase with user
authentication and firestore you'll be
looking at around 500 kilobytes and AWS
with app sync and graph QL is close to a
full megabyte and the main j/s violence
felt I'm going to import amplify from
amplify core and then I'm going to call
configure on it with our configuration
details that were automatically
generated by the CLI from there I'll
just go into the app component and then
when this component is mounted I'll go
ahead and call off current user to see
if the current user is logged in so just
one line of code to check if the users
logged in and then if we want to log in
with email and password we can call off
sign-in with
user name and password and that's all it
takes to get a user signed in and then
we can set that user as the user
property on this component now if we
click the login button it's going to log
us in with AWS kognito and it'll show
our user name here in the UI and I don't
think it gets any easier than that as
far as user authentication goes now if
we switch over to our firebase branch we
have these same basic set up here we
initialize the SDK with our credentials
from the firebase console and then from
there we'll go into the main app
component and you'll notice that the
code is almost identical to AWS amplifi
we're simply calling auth current user
to get the current user and then we say
sign in with email and password to sign
the user in now the point I'm trying to
make here is that both SDKs provide
well-organized JavaScript libraries that
help you get things done with very few
lines of code but now I want to switch
gears here to real-time data and that's
where things really start to get
interesting I'll go ahead and start by
showing you the firebase example we're
here in the firestore database and we're
creating a document in a to do x'
collection the user needs to be able to
view this data and update the data and
also stay up to date with any changes
that happen to it in real time across
all clients and that's a very
challenging requirement to not only
implement but also to do it scale if we
look at the app itself the user should
be able to tap this mark complete button
and then see the data updated in the UI
and then also in the backend as well to
implement this code we'll go ahead and
import firestorm and then we'll make a
reference to that - duze collection in
the database to query the collection we
just call on snapshot and that will give
us a callback function that will listen
to any changes to that collection in
real time it's going to give us a
snapshot that contains an array of the
document data and then we can map that
snapshot down to an actual JavaScript
object that we can show here in our
front-end application and that's
actually all it takes to listen to a
real-time stream of data now if we want
to mutate or update a specific to-do
item we just make a reference to its
location in the database and then we
call update on that reference with the
new data that we want to send and in our
case we want to update a to-do item to
complete which we can do with a single
line of code
so with fire store you get simplicity
without any boilerplate code that makes
it really easy to work with especially
if you're building complex real-time
features because all of the difficult
real-time stuff is done for you
automatically under the hood but the
major drawback is that you're stuck
working with a single no sequel database
that may present
challenges for data modeling and can
also be hard to migrate into or migrate
out of let's go ahead and switch back to
amplify to see how this looks with graph
QL and app sync we're going to first run
amplify ad API to provision these
resources in the project will choose
graph QL so we can use real-time
features and make sure to choose API for
the authentication type now with graph
QL there's a lot of boilerplate code but
the nice thing about the amplifi CLI is
that it's going to walk you through that
code and generate most of it for you
conveniently the default schema matches
the data type that we already have set
up in our front-end app I'm just going
to add a boolean property called
complete from there you can run amplify
push and then it will ask you if you
want to automatically generate the graph
QL API
select yes and in this demo I'll select
JavaScript as the language go ahead and
select yes to everything else and it's
going to finish up by giving you a graph
QL API endpoint as well as an API key
then head over to the app sync console
and you'll find a schema has been
generated and uploaded to the cloud for
you this is really cool because you now
have a graph QL API deployed that can be
accessed by any client that has that API
key and it took almost no effort on our
part but the API itself is pretty
useless unless there's a back-end data
source attached to it amplify will
automatically set up an instance of
dynamodb which is a no sequel database
that is roughly equivalent to MongoDB or
firestore now we can go into the
database and we'll go ahead and create a
new item that matches the schema that we
have set up and graph QL now if we go
back to our source code you'll see that
there's an automatically generated graph
QL folder in the source directory this
contains all the boilerplate code that
you need for graph QL for things like
mutations queries and subscriptions now
there's a few different ways we could
query this data with graph QL but the
gold standard way is to use the Apollo
client so we'll go ahead and install an
AWS app sync and graph QL tag in this
project and then I'm creating a new
javascript file called client j s that
is just here to initialize AWS app sync
from there we'll go into our app
component and then we'll import that
client as well as the list to do use
query from the graph QL directory now we
can make a query for the actual data in
the database by saying graph QL list to
do's and that will return a promise that
resolves into the actual data from the
database which will be an array of
to do items so that provides a
relatively easy way to fetch the data
but at this point it's not real time if
the user clicks mark complete it's going
to update the item in the database but
it's not going to actually notify us of
that change we'll go ahead and run the
mutation as well as the subscription to
real-time updates in this to do
component we'll need the update to do
mutation as well as the on update to do
subscription and then to update the data
will call client mutate and then pass in
an object that contains the data that we
want to change on that database record
in DynamoDB now that's going to take
care of the update but we still want to
listen to real-time changes to make that
happen we'll go ahead and set up a
subscription here that listens to the
update on this to-do item we'll go ahead
and call client subscribe and then point
it to a query of the on update to do
subscription and then we'll call
subscribe on that which will give us
access to the data whenever it changes
once we have access to that new data we
can just go ahead and update the
property on this component so now when
this mutation runs on the back end it's
going to update the UI on the front end
now I probably would not build an app
like this in the real world but I just
want to give you an idea of what it
takes to get things set up with real
time data in AWS app sync graph QL is a
really amazing tool but in a lot of
cases it might just be overkill we have
a lot of complexity in this app both an
automatically generated code and our own
implementation details for something
that was implemented relatively easily
with firestore but again the big trade
out there is we now have a lot more
flexibility to make the code behave
exactly the way we want it to I want to
finish things off by saying that both
platforms are awesome in their own ways
and it's hard for me to imagine going
back to building a back-end from scratch
these services will save you time and
money and help you get your product in
front of customers faster now to some of
the comparison I would say that pricing
is almost equivalent one might be
cheaper than the other depending on how
you use it I would say firebase is
generally easier to use and there are
fewer decisions to make when getting
things configured and that's especially
true when you compare a graph QL and
DynamoDB to firestore but on the other
hand AWS is superior when it comes to
flexibility there are more knobs to turn
that you can use to customize the
experience specific to your needs I'm
going to go ahead and wrap things up
there and if you have experience with
both amplify and firebase I'd really
like to hear your thoughts in the
comments thanks for watching and I will
talk to you soon it might be a tumor
it's not a tumor
it's not a tuma at all